We all know that you should stay away from toxins like mercury
A 200-mg dose will kill you
Or polonium, which requires only a gram of material vapor to wipe out 50 million people
But you know that 70 cups of coffee contains caffeine
Enough to kill a person weighing 70 kg?
This amount of caffeine can cause heart palpitations or even cardiac arrest.
Your favorite choice of drinks is alcohol?
13 consecutive cups can be fatal too!
Because alcohol is inhibitory it stops
The brain area that controls basic life functions
Such as breathing and heart rate.
Too much fluid can generally be dangerous.
Although the effect of water poisoning takes a long time about 6 liters causes a tumor in brain cells
Leading to headaches, convulsions, coma and death in extreme cases,
But if you do not drink water or consume too much salt,
Your cells will begin to contract, leading to a condition known as hypernatermia,
48 teaspoons of your favorite spice at one time
Enough to cause this interaction
Which also leads to convulsions, coma or even death.
Immerse your head underwater or simply hold yourself
This will take about 4 minutes without oxygen
Causing a severe brain injury that causes your death within 6 minutes.
Only in rare cases can some divers
Hold their breath for more than 20 minutes.
The rice can also deprive you of oxygen!
what do you say?!
If you've swallowed the cherry seed, do not worry too much.
Just do not bite another pill.
Contains one or two grains of wild cherry seeds
On cyanide and it is enough to eliminate you.
Cyanokride ions inhibit cystochrome (coenzyme)
And makes your cells unable to use oxygen.
Speaking of hypoxia,
At an altitude of 8,000 feet above sea level
Our bodies can not adapt to the limited amount of oxygen
Which is known as the "death zone" in mountain climbing
Just because it is too high can kill you.
In 1930 he arrived (Robert Pershing) to 8 feet and 11 inches
This high pressure caused the circulatory system
And structural pressure on his bones,
He died at the age of 22 years.
Researchers assume that every 2 cm above 5 feet decreases 1.3 years of your life.
If you are concerned about the life of your pet you must have heard of not giving them chocolate
The same chemical (theobromine) can also kill us.
Oxidation of our bodies (theobromine) more effectively
Although 1,000 mg / kg would be fatal to humans
Which is equivalent to 85 full size chocolate plates at the same time.
You can crave a lot of chocolate after your sprouting,
But you need to eat 22 kilograms of marijuana to become at risk of dying
The amount required for the overdose is to smoke a large bottle of it
About 60 kilograms of marijuana and just 15 minutes to stimulate death!
Which explains why no single death is documented
Directly related to the consumption of a large amount of marijuana!
Raising your music may be amazing and fun too
Just do not raise it higher than 185 decibels
The amount of atmospheric pressure resulting from it can blow up your lungs
Or alternatively a clogged configuration can settle in your heart.
It can also keep your neighbors awake all night.
While it is uncertain how much the body can survive without sleep,
Studies were conducted on mice who were subjected to continuous sleep deprivation
It lasted about two weeks before her death.
The world record for human beings is more than 11 days,
But surprisingly no long-term effects were documented
After he was prevented from sleeping.
Got the urgent question you want to answer?
Ask in comments or on Facebook and Twitter
If you like this video
See our previous section "These 200 Calories"
We will analyze and compare different foods and drinks
To put things in perspective.
Translation: team translate @autrjim